[Musique]
louis 15 occupe une position peu
enviable dans l'histoire de france
il se situe entre la gloire et les
splendeurs du roi soleil dont on oublie
souvent le régime absolutiste et
l'explosion de la révolution française
qui mènera au régicide on ne connaît pas
très bien ce monarque qui monta sur le
trône après louis xiv et avant louis
saez est une question se pose lorsqu'on
examine son renne un roi d'une autre
stature aurait-il pu empêcher la
révolution il était le seul espoir
l'espoir de la france c'était le seul à
pouvoir porter la couronne louis 15e n'a
pas été à la fin de son règne très
populaire on dit le bien aimé en forme
de dérision ce surnom bien aimé c'est un
petit peu galvaudé c'est un petit peu le
bien aimé des dames 8 14 était un roi
que l'on avait aimé et pardonner pour
ses guerres
louis 15 ne le pardonnera pas parce
qu'il va les perdre
[Musique]
la monarchie absolue ne vaut que par son
monarque les succès de louis xiv était
lié à son caractère hyper actif et à sa
capacité à tout contrôle et louis 15 au
contraire manqué de confiance et
n'appréciait pas le rôle public qu'il
devait assumer
il fut très populaire pendant la
première partie de son règne
le climat était plutôt à l'optimisme
avec son avènement la population se prit
à espérer des jours meilleurs
mais la france du xviiie siècle va
connaître des changements radicaux
après plusieurs décennies de répression
les idées progressistes vont se
développer au cours de ce qu'on
appellera le siècle des lumières
l'autorité en général va se trouver
remise en question et sur ce fond de
changement social
la sauvegarde de l'autocratie va se
révéler être au delà des capacités de
louis 15 ses échecs en matière politique
financière et morale vont accélérer le
déclin de la monarchie
[Musique]
louis xiv arrière grand père et
prédécesseur de louis 15 connu un règne
d'une longueur sans précédent 72 ans
sous l'autorité suprême du roi la france
se développa jusqu'à devenir l'un des
pays les plus puissants au monde est une
référence dans le domaine artistique
louis xiv se vantait d'être le premier
roi de france à connaître ses arrière
petits fils tout en étant encore en
bonne santé
[Musique]
ces trois génération d'héritiers assuré
sans aucun doute la pérennité de la
lignée des bourbons mais au cours des
dernières années de son règne la mort va
planer au dessus de la famille royale
le roi doit affronter de douloureuse
disparition qui vont mettre en péril sa
succession au trône de france le grand
dauphin ses deux fils aînés de louis xiv
on a inventé pour lui l'expression
monseigneur s'adresse à lui en
l'appelant monseigneur alors on disait
de lui qu'il allait être fils de roi
qu'il allait être père de roy et jamais
roi et set fut exactement ça puisque
finalement il fut le fils de louis xiv
et de marie thérèse d'autriche
il fut le père de philippe 5 d'espagne
et il ne règne à jamais le fils de louis
xiv le grand dauphin mort soudain au
printemps 17 111 laissant derrière lui
trois fils l'aîné le duc de bourgogne
devient le nouveau dauphin avec son
adorable femme marie adélaïde de savoie
il a lui-même deux fils le duc de
bretagne et le petit louis duc d'anjou
ce titre étant généralement réservé aux
plus jeune de la fratrie
mais en 1712 le dauphin et son épouse
contracté la rougeole et disparaissent à
leur tour peu après leur fils aîné le
duc de bretagne succombent à la même
maladie le cadet louis duc d'anjou
survit miraculeusement grâce à sa
gouvernante madame de ventadour qui
interdit aux médecins de l'approché et
le soigne elle même il devient le
premier dans l'ordre de succession au
trône leur soleil à deux autres petits
fils philippe cinq rois d'espagne qui a
renoncé à toute prétention au trône de
france et charles duc de berry qui meurt
en 1714 à 28 ans des suites d'un
accident de chasse le plus long règne de
l'histoire de france touche à sa fin
avec la mort de louis xiv en 1715 à
l'âge de 77 ans le destin du pays est
liée à la survie de son fragile arrière
petit fils alors âgé de cinq ans alors
on connaît la scène quand louis xiv et
sur son lit d'agonie
il fait venir le seul héritier de la
couronne qui lui reste c'est à dire son
arrière petit fils qui va devenir louis
15 d'une seconde à l'autre et il lui dit
j'ai trop aimé la guerre en cela ne me
mettais jamais et en effet il a aimé la
guerre à tel point que les caisses de la
france sont archi vide le royaume est
dans un état de misère
terrible louis xiv laisse derrière lui
son château de versailles près de paris
qui pendant des années a été le siège de
la cour et de la noblesse française au
cours de son règne il a transformé le
modeste pavillon de chasse paternel en
un château somptueux avec des jardins
des terrasses des sculptures magnifique
un lac un zoo et près de 500 fontaine
plus de dix mille personnes y résident
toute l'europe voulait imiter le style
de louis xiv
les oeuvres d'art le mobilier
larchitecture l'étiquette hélas pas le
roi possédait une telle force de
caractère qu'il avait marqué de son
empreinte tout le siècle
mais l'ancien régime avait à peine
atteint son apogée qu'il commença
lentement a décliné la décision de son
grand-père de révoqué l'édit de nantes
par lequel henri iv avait instauré la
liberté religieuse a fait fuir du pays
des milliers de huguenots
c'est un gros coup porté à l'industrie
et au commerce
la france s'en est retrouvé affaibli et
ses ennemis renforcer le départ des
huguenots qui étaient des banquiers des
financiers et financer l'industrie c'est
une source qui s'est tari pour
l'industrie française l'industrie qui
était quand même balbutiante et on peut
dire que les conditions économiques de
l'avènement d'un nouveau roi en
l'occurrence il s'agissait surtout d'une
régence n'étaient pas fameuses
un demi-siècle de guerre et d'impôts
écrasant ont laissé le pays épuisé
accablé par la pauvreté et sans espoir
à la fin du règne de louis xiv la
stabilité de la monarchie remise en
question des critiques s'élèvent pour
dénoncer la guerre et les iniquités
sociales et pour réclamer une réforme
fiscale
à l'aube du xviiie siècle on voit naître
les débuts d'une véritable opposition
tous les espoirs se portent sur le bel
enfant mois lorsqu'il accède au trône en
1715 la population a soif de nouveauté
le petit prince bourbon est charmant et
à une allure majestueuse
mais la tradition exige qu une régence
soit mis en place jusqu'à la majorité du
souverain alors fixé à 13 ans philippe
d'orléans neveu de louis xiv devient
donc régent et va gouverner la france
durant les sept années qui suivent
c'est un homme aimable et qui montre une
véritable affection pour son neveu ses
premières décisions marquent
immédiatement un changement en tant que
libéral il est favorable à un équilibre
des pouvoirs et redonne aux parlements
régionaux
certains de ceux que louis xiv leur
avait enlevé sa décision de transférer
la cour de versailles à paris est
hautement symbolique elle aussi
le petit louis 15 est d'abord installés
dans les parties récente du château
médiéval de vincennes puis au palais des
tuileries à paris
son oncle réside non loin au palais
royal
philippe d'orléans ne se soucie guère de
l'étiquette ni de la bienséance
ils préfèrent les femmes et la boisson
plaisir auquel il se livre la nuit venue
et les gens de la noblesse fonds domaine
alors le région n'a pas que des qualités
évidemment le régent est un est un
fieffé libertin le régent est un des
mots chez on le sait il a des amis et
des ministres avec lesquels il fait des
soirées crapuleuses à n'en plus finir ce
qu'on appelait les soupers du régent ou
les femmes arrivent et se donne est
nullement génie sur les tables etc
cette tolérance nouvelle entraîne une
atmosphère de liberté paris change
radicalement la ville s'adonne à la
boisson au jeu à la fête et au luxe
on assiste à une étrange dichotomie
entre le relâchement des moeurs et le
raffinement des divertissements mais le
problème de la dette nationale persiste
les efforts du régent vers une
modernisation du système financier
donnent leurs premiers résultats le
régent va également être le responsable
d'une véritable évolution financière
puisque en france on va faire confiance
un banquier
las en saas écrit elle à w mais on le on
le dit bien de cette façon là ce et
c'est en fait la première monnaie qui
arrive en france et c'est d'ailleurs une
technique extraordinaire on achète du
papier et tout un blesse va faire
confiance toute la france va faire
confiance à l'as jusqu'au jour où
effectivement certains demandent à être
remboursés
et c'est la banqueroute
pendant un temps la france prospère mais
les prémices de libéralisme vont prendre
fin en même temps que la régence le
régent bien intentionné mais
inexpérimenté à épuiser les bonnes
volontés et son comportements licencieux
a entaché la réputation morale de la
monarchie son échec le contraint à se
retirer et le ramène la cour à
versailles en 1722 cette distance entre
le roi et la capitale aura de lourdes
conséquences dans le futur louis 15 et
couronnée en octobre dans la cathédrale
de reims et il atteint sa majorité
quatre mois plus tard on février 1723
c'est la fin de la régence philippe
d'orléans meurt de ses excès dans les
bras de l'une de ses maîtresses la même
année
[Musique]
louis 15 a grandi orphelin il hérite le
prestige de ses parents mais il aurait
volontiers échangé celui ci contre leur
affection
bien que sa gouvernante madame de
ventadour l'entourent de sa tendresse
son enfance est cependant solitaire et
douloureuse
malgré son jeune âge il se conduit avec
une grande maturité durant la cérémonie
du couronnement
il salue les étrangers venus en nombre
avec calme et dignité
éduquer à ne pas laisser paraître ses
vrais sentiments
il a fini par assimiler parfaitement
cette leçon les contemporains de louis
15 ainsi que les historiens s'accordent
à dire qu'il n'était plus cultivée est
plus intelligente que son
arrière-grand-père mais qui ne
manquaient terriblement de confiance en
lui louis 15 est un jeune homme charmant
très élégant on dit que c'est le le plus
beau français du royaume parce qu'il est
très bien fait de sa personne il est
grand il est beau un visage remarquable
il a des yeux bleus très très pénétrants
quand on regarde les carnets de présence
de deux week-ends dans son bureau on
voit très bien que louis 15 est un homme
qui travaille qui est au travail et
qu'il n'est pas toujours en train de
prendre du plaisir
une faute majeure l'heureux se révèle
vif d'une grande curiosité
intellectuelle emprunt de moralité et
naturellement beau mais il n'a que 13
ans
il a besoin d'un réjean officieux d'un
ministre pour diriger le pays et le
conseiller
mais lorsqu'on cherche une main ferme
pour tenir la barre on s'aperçoit que le
choix est limité
c'est son cousin louis ix henri princes
du sang issu de la lignée des bourbons
qui remplit quelques temps ce rôle il
est relevé de ses fonctions en 1726 est
remplacé par le cardinal de fleury
précepteur du roi et qui depuis la mort
du régent a conquis les faveurs du jeune
roi
en attendant patiemment son heure louis
15 jouit d'une excellente image au début
de son règne on le surnomme le bien aimé
le cardinal de fleury restera son
premier ministre pendant 17 ans
tout au long de la période la plus
heureuse d'un règne malheureux pendant
les premières années de son règne
louis 15 est bien perçu par ce que il
incarne l'espoir l'espérance la fin d'un
certain despotisme et là où ils méritent
précisément ce surnom justifier de bien
aimer c'est un c'est un jeune roi qui
veut essayer d'éviter la guerre autant
qu'il est possible parce que il suit en
cela le conseil de son arrière grand
père agonisant et la france ma foi ne le
sont pas si mal
louis qui a maintenant 15 ans est en âge
de se marier une union et conclut en
1725 entre le roi de france est la fille
du roi détrôné de pologne
marc il exhume ce cas de sept ans son
aîné ce choix choqué iric la cour qui
parle de mes alliances mais il avait été
fait pour d'enfance et aucune des
puissantes cours qu'ils convoitaient le
trône de france marie va donner à son
époux dix enfants en disant cette
deviendront adultes
trois filles sont nées avant le 1er
garçon qui voit le jour
en 1729 c'est une joie immense et cette
naissance donne lieu à de grandes
festivités
la popularité de louis 15 grandi il est
reconnaissant à son épouse de lui avoir
donné ses enfants et ils forment pendant
un long moment un couple heureux à la
grande stupéfaction de la cour le roi
sera fidèle à la reine durant sept ans
jour marie leczinska n'en pouvant plus
lui dit on le sait toujours grosse
toujours couchée toujours à coucher
c'est fini on peut dormir ensemble et on
ne couche plus ensemble pour un louis 15
qui relativement porté sur la chose
c'est absolument impossible donc on veut
fur et à mesure du temps va se tourner
vers des maîtresses officiel que l'on
pourrait lui mettre dans son lit pour
apaiser son appétit
le cardinal de fleury est un ministre
très populaire il parvient à stabiliser
la monnaie et à équilibrer le budget il
réussit également à éviter la guerre à
l'exception d'un court conflit avec
l'autriche qui aboutit à l'acquisition
de la précieuse province de lorraine il
devient premier ministre à l'âge de 73
ans ce qui donne de bonnes raisons de
penser que louis 15 ne va pas tarder à
accéder au pouvoir
le roi va prendre de plus en plus de
responsabilités au sein du gouvernement
pendant les années 1730 tout en laissant
croire que le cardinal géré seul les
affaires de l'état
mais l'incapacité du roi à s'affirmer
est embarrassante et devient la source
de nombreuses rumeurs
on commence à penser qu'il n'a pas les
qualités nécessaires pour régner la
présence permanente du cardinal de
fleury devient un véritable frein à
l'épanouissement du roi en 1738
il commence à ressentir un besoin
croissant de s'émanciper mais son
premier ministre qui a maintenant 85 ans
ne montre aucun signe de faiblesse
louis 15 a déjà 30 ans quand son
ministre moeurs enfin il assure enfin
seul le pouvoir au moment où la france
est sur le point d'entrer en guerre en
1740 charles ciss chef de la maison des
habsbourgs et chef du saint-empire
romain germanique meurt subitement les
circonstances sont réunies pour qu'un
conflit éclate en europe
louis 15 n'est pas un homme belliqueux
mais la guerre de succession d'autriche
concerne toutes les puissances
européennes et la france est obligée de
choisir son camp charles ciss va laisser
à sa fille marie thérèse un empire
énorme
évidemment ça suscite l'appétit des pays
voisins
alors la france est allié à l'espagne et
à la prusse tandis que l'autriche a
comme allié l'angleterre et les
provinces-unies frédéric ii de prusse et
la fille de charles le 6 marie thérèse
se dispute bientôt la province de
silésie les britanniques rejoignent
l'autriche et la france voit là
l'occasion de briser le lien entre
l'autriche et le saint-empire alliée à
la prusse louis 15 remporte une série de
victoires importantes
la bataille de fontenoy reste dans les
mémoires comme l'une des plus grandes
victoires françaises contre les
britanniques en 1748
la france occupe l'ensemble des pays bas
autrichiens et semble être en voie
d'accomplir son rêve
l'extension de sa frontière nord-est
jusqu'au rhin à la fin de la guerre le
roi est au sommet de sa popularité
le rôle oui 15 est également célèbre par
sa maîtresse
madame de pompadour la vie étonnante et
l'extraordinaire ascension vers le
pouvoir de cette femme dotée d'esprit
d'intelligence et de beauté qui fut à la
fois adoré hays est devenu une légende
jeanne antoinette poisson n'est à paris
le 29 décembre 10 721 elle est la fille
aînée de françois poisson écuyers de son
altesse royale qui avait débuté comme
transporteur de vivre dans l'armée et de
louise madeleine de la motte la famille
poisson appartient à la classe moyenne
mais jouit des avantages que lui procure
des amis haut placés
alors monsieur poisson lui il est
contraint à l'exil suite d'une affaire
de fournitures aux armées qui tourne mal
et puis la jeune jeanne poisson reste
avec sa mère et sa mère un riche
protecteur et ses protecteurs s'occupe
de l'éducation de jeunes poissons veille
à ce qu'elle fréquente les salons
qu'elle est de la conversation une
diseuse de bonne aventure ayant dit à la
fillette alors âgée de 9 ans qu'elle
serait un jour la maîtresse de louis 15
sa mère décide de la préparer à ce rôle
la prophétie ne semblait guère avoir de
chance de se réaliser car contrairement
à son prédécesseur le roi ne cherchait
pas le réconfort en dehors des liens du
mariage
cependant jeanne antoinette qui a
toujours rêvé de rencontrer le roi dont
on dit qu'il est le plus bel homme de
france est maintenant persuadé qu'elle
est promise à un grand destin
ces caractéristiques de cette époque où
une jeune fille de la bourgeoisie
pouvait aspirer à s'élever jusqu'au plus
haut rang de la société après sept ans
de mariage
l'intérêt de louis 15 pour son épouse
modeste et dévoué commence à décliner
bien que timide il est prêt à accepter
les avances d'autres femmes et jette
d'abord son dévolu sur trois soeurs qui
deviendront tour à tour sa maîtresse
louis 15 avait fait appel à son ministre
des plaisirs comme il l'appelait qui lui
avait dit je connais une petite jeune
femme qui s'appelle louise louise le
masi louise demailly neil qui est belle
comme un coeur et qui s'étiole qui
s'ennuient vous pourriez peut-être aller
lui dire deux mots et en effet on l'a vu
dans les couloirs de versailles sont
allés nuitamment pour rejoindre la
petite louise de my dinh elle qui a été
sa première maîtresse et comme il avait
l'esprit de famille louis 15 et bien
quand il en a eu assez de louise de
maddie il a pris sa soeur cadette et
ensuite sa soeur balsamine en la
personne de celle qu'il fera d'ailleurs
duchesse de châteauroux la première des
soeurs de nesle et louise julie comtesse
de mailly puis sa soeur pauline marquise
de vintimille devient la favorite du roi
et lorsque celle ci meurt en couches
c'est une troisième soeur qui arrive à
versailles
[Musique]
marianne demailly neil duchesse de
châteauroux est la plus jeune et la plus
jolie
so rôle politique grandit en coulisses
et elle use de son influence pour que le
roi conclu une alliance avec frédéric ii
de prusse qui sera signé en 1744
après un rendez vous amoureux à metz
entre deux batailles le roi tombe malade
et lutte quelques jours entre la vie et
la mort le peuple prie pour que dieu
vienne en aide à son bien-aimé roi mais
le prêtre refuse de lui accorder
l'extrême onction tant qu'il n'aura pas
congédié sa maîtresse et demandé
l'absolution pour son comportement
adultérin le roi n'a d'autre choix que
de s'y résigner
il se rétablit cependant peu après et
rentre à versailles mais juste avant de
le rejoindre
madame de châteauroux tombent malades et
meurent de façon mystérieuse dévoré par
le chagrin louis 15 se console un moment
dans les bras d'une quatrième soeur de
neil madame de lauragais c'est lors de
ce chapitre de la vie amoureuse du roi
que jeanne antoinette poisson fait son
entrée dans la société parisienne ayant
acquis les manières du monde est doté de
tous les talents
elle est grande masse est lancée et
possède une démarche des plus gracieuse
son visage et d'un ovale parfait
elle a des cheveux châtain clair son
sourire découvre d'impeccables dents
blanches et ses yeux sont dinguerie
persan elle fréquente les fameux salon
parisien qui accorde aux femmes une
fonction culturelle importante
madame d'etiolles car c'est son nom
maintenant se conforme au mode de vie de
la bonne société
elle reçoit dans sa propriété d'etiolles
près de paris et donne des
représentations privé dans le petit
théâtre
kelly a fait construire
elle devient rapidement connue comme
l'une des dames les plus séduisantes de
paris cette propriété se trouve
justement près du château de choisy que
le roi a acquis peu de temps auparavant
il entend parler de la ravissante madame
bettiol et la croiser au cours d'une
chasse en forêt de sénart avoir une
technique absolument fabuleuse pour se
faire repérer de louis 15 elle va
habiller son phaéton de bleus quand elle
est habillée de rose et elle va habiller
son feuilleton de rose quand elle est
habillée de bleu va et on étend le
véhicule et louis 15 la repère il va
l'inviter un bal masqué en 1745 on
février 1745 le fameux bal des ifs alors
ton été décoré en en ifa et louis 15
c'est certainement ce soir là qu'il jeta
son mouchoir à madame de pompadour après
une romance est clair louis 15 choque
tout le monde
en choisissant comme nouvelle favorite
une personne issue de la bourgeoisie
madame des thiolettes installé au
troisième étage du château juste au
dessus du bureau et de la chambre du roi
ils lui offrent ensuite le titre de
marquise de pompadour ne laissant plus
aucun doute sur le fait que la position
tant convoité de mes traces officielle
est dorénavant occupée madame de
pompadour brille dans ce nouveau rôle
elle organise des dîners informel dans
ces petits appartements que l'on peut
encore admirer de nos jours le roi qui
préféra mode de vie plus bourgeois que
son ancêtre trouve dans les appartements
privés de sa maîtresse une intimité et
la présence féminine rassurante dont il
a été privé durant son enfance
madame de pompadour consolide peu à peu
son pouvoir à la cour et se met à exercé
une grande influence sur la politique et
la culture du pays
le peuple cependant n'apprécie pas son
mode de vie somptueux et son ingérence
dans la politique de la france
[Musique]
malgré les critiques madame de pompadour
et sincèrement soucieuse du bonheur de
son amant et c'est ainsi qu'elle
participe largement à la culture de son
époque
madame de pompadour a été pour loïc 15
j'allais dire son éminence rose en
quelque sorte parce que d'abord sa
psychologue ou sa psychothérapeute parce
que louis 15 était quelqu'un de
dépressif récurrents il avait des
pressions considérables et elle le
soignait à sa manière c'est à dire en
organisant des soirées en jouant des
pièces de théâtre en lui faisant faire
la cuisine
et puis surtout en étant son ministre
des beaux-arts je crois que le véritable
premier ministre de la culture dans
l'histoire c'est madame de pompadour
si le règne de louis 15 est souvent
considérée comme l'apogée de
l'architecturé française et des arts
décoratifs
c'est en grande partie grâce au mécénat
exercée par la marquise
madame de pompadour c'est la création la
porcelaine de sèvres
c'est le renouveau la porcelaine de
france mais c'est aussi des châteaux
qu'à l'acheter qu'à la rénover qu'elle
revendait avec beaucoup de bénéfices
crécy champs-sur-marne ménard la
celle-saint-cloud également l'hôtel
d'evreux 1 qui deviendra l'elysée le
fait bâtir des quantités de monuments
l'école militaire
elle est occupé une place capitale dans
l'époque louis 15 et quand on parle du
style louis qu'un stade sur le style un
peu rococo et bien on devrais je crois
historiquement dire le style pompadour
madame de pompadour est une
collectionneuse passionnée d'oeuvre
d'art et de mobilier précieux en tant
que mécène royal elle assure la
subsistance d'artistes ainsi que de leur
famille durant de nombreuses années le
style que l'on associe à l'europe du
xviiie siècle est appelée rococo l'art
en constante évolution reflète les idées
et les aspirations de son époque
ce nouveau style reflète la réaction
règles rigides établi par louis xiv
auparavant l'académie royale contrôler
la vie artistique du pays
la période de la régence amorce un
changement décisif
le rococo ressemble au théâtre baroque
mais à une échelle plus petite plus
intime et plus légère les paysages et la
peinture de guerre deviennent à la mode
et l'on voit apparaître un courant de
sensualité raffinés parmi les premiers
peintres de ce style décadent on trouve
antoine bateau et françois boucher leur
modèle et le peintre flamand pierre paul
rubens chez qu'il trouve tout ce que
l'académie désapprouvait couleurs
lumières mouvement est un plaisir
évident de la vie antoine bateau est un
grand coloriste connu pour avoir créé un
genre bien personnelle qu'on appelle les
fêtes galantes
ce sont des scènes charmante idyllique
et bucolique baigné dans une atmosphère
théâtrale emprunté à la comédie
italienne
[Musique]
françois boucher a la chance d'avoir
pour mécènes l'illustrent madame de
pompadour vato est bouché capte l'esprit
de la société parisienne où les nobles
se plaisent à jouer la comédie
comme si leur vie était aussi
insouciante que celle du berger et de la
bergère des tableaux
joe honoré fragonard et quant à lui à
mettre de la fin du mouvement rococo la
demande des mécènes de la cour de louis
15 l'amène à se tourner pour un temps
vers ces scènes d'amour et de volupté
auquel est associé son nom
on découvre d'autres artistes
remarquables comme les portraitistes de
la cour oui michel vent l'eau maurice
quentin de la tour et jean-marc nattier
lé premier peintre du roi sont françois
lemoine et charles antoine coypel les
soeurs de la rukoko au cours de la
première moitié du siècle reflète
l'esprit de la noblesse et sa liberté
retrouvée
mais le mouvement intellectuel qui
l'accompagnent a une portée plus large
et une influence sur toutes les couches
de la société
après la magnificence et la parade du
grand siècle de louis xiv apparaît le
xviiie siècle avec sa grâce ses charmes
et ses plaisirs et avec lui n'est une
nouvelle curiosité intellectuelle
le fameux siècle des lumières donne
naissance à une révolution des idées qui
présage de la révolution politique à
venir
madame de pompadour c'est une femme qui
a beaucoup beaucoup d'ouverture et si
finalement louis 15 rentrer tout
doucement dans la philosophie des
lumières si le siècle de louis 15
rentrer tout doucement de la philosophie
des lumières on le doit en grande partie
à cette femme qui a permis l'évolution
des idées et qui a fait en sorte que
l'ensemble des artistes puissent
s'épanouir et dire sans véritablement se
cacher ce qu'ils pensaient il faut
savoir que c'était un petit peu grâce à
madame de pompadour que la fameuse
encyclopédie régler les philosophes
contestataires les écrivains tels que
voltaire tels que diderot tels que
rousseau tels que d'alembert vont être
autorisés à publier leurs écrits parce
que louis 15 voulait les censurer à
l'origine les lumières sont un mouvement
culturel et philosophique qui va agir
comme un catalyseur des courants
intellectuels du xviiie siècle
les penseurs de l'époque soutiennent que
la raison peut permettre de combattre
l'ignorance la superstition et la
tyrannie et de construire un monde
meilleur
cette affirmation entraîne une remise en
question de la tradition et de
l'autorité dont les cibles principales
sont l'église catholique et
l'aristocratie à caractère héréditaire
c'est l'époque des grands philosophes
que son montesquieu voltaire et rousseau
quelles que soient leurs opinions
politiques
ils plaident tous pour la liberté civile
et de nombreux monarque eux se sentent
menacés par ces idées nouvelles
voltaire est connu pour avoir transformé
le climat intellectuel de l'époque
les partisans de la libre pensée de la
tolérance religieuse de loi plus
clémente de finances saines de
l'absurdité des guerres et avant tout
c'est un humaniste forcé de s'exiler à
cause de ses idées libérales
il se réfugie un temps à la cour du
grand prince des lumières frédéric ii de
prusse
il ouvre la voie à cette armée de
penseurs emmené par les encyclopédistes
qui reprendront le flambeau dans le
dernier quart du siècle
ces érudits font partie du mouvement
libéral favorable réformes qu'on appelle
partie philosophique en opposition
partie des baies vaud qui défend les
intérêts de l'église
madame de pompadour est une libérale
elle soutient son ami voltaire les
éditeurs des encyclopédistes et denis
diderot contre les attaques de l'église
c'est elle également qui manoeuvrent
pour faire entrer au conseil du roi des
acteurs du parti philosophique
[Musique]
la guerre de succession d'autriche
s'achève avec le second traité d'aix la
chapelle en 1748 louis 15 choc la
population du royaume en acceptant de
restituer les pays-bas à l'autriche cela
marque un virage dans sa popularité
l'année suivante afin de combler le
déficit budgétaire
il approuve sur les conseils de madame
de pompadour l'instauration d'un impôt
sur le revenu qui s'applique également à
ceux qui bénéficient de privilèges
elle va proposer à louis 15 d'instaurer
le 20e le 20e était un impôt pour tous
un impôt qui était à la fois pour la
noblesse et à la fois pour les religieux
dont imaginez-vous c'est la catastrophe
en france qui est cette femme qui est
cette bourgeoise qui vient imposer la
totalité de la population
on ne peut le souffrir c'est une
première dans l'histoire de france
de violentes protestations s'élèvent et
la pression est telle que leroy finit
par exemptés de ces taxes le clergé les
parlements obtiennent la victoire en
faisant bloc contre toutes les réformes
visant à transformer le système de
l'impôt foncier ou celui des privilèges
des classes possédantes
craignant les réformes les parlements
cherche tous les moyens de monter le
peuple contre le roi il lance contre le
souverain et madame de pompadour une
campagne de diffamation qui leur permet
de gagner du terrain
la population désapprouvent de plus en
plus les nombreuses infidélités du roi
sa relation avec la marquise cesse
d'être amoureuse pour devenir amical à
partir de 1750 il s'embourbe dans des
relations sexuelles fugace attiré par
les jeunes filles il en loge certaine
dans son arène personnel le parc aux
cerfs marie louise o murphy qui restent
à 2752 à 1755 et immortalisé dans un
tableau de boucher
l'appétit sexuel de louis 15 n'est pas
unique en son genre parmi les monarques
françois 1er henri iv et louis xiv
étaient tous des coureurs de jupons
notoire
ce qui est différent à présent c'est le
niveau de conscience du peuple
mais en vieillissant louis qu'un ce
souci de moins en moins des conventions
il semble qu'ils soient conscients que
les forces anti monarchique menace son
règne et la légitimité de s'aligner mais
ne parvient pas à les arrêter sa
timidité l'empêchent de prendre vraiment
les choses en main et il se laisse
influencer par une favorite puis une
autre ce qui accentue les dissensions
qui perturbe son règne après avoir
conclu la paix avec l'autriche le roi
veut que le pays connaisse enfin la paix
la france se bâtit un empire dans les
indes et le nouveau monde et ne cherche
plus à s'emparer des territoires de ses
voisins en 1755 l'angleterre attaque la
france et déclenché un conflit colonial
la prusse abandonne alors son allié
français louis 15 ne vois pas d'autre
solution que d'accepter une alliance
avec l'autriche
il est convaincu qu'avec son soutien il
pourra empêcher la guerre
ils se trompent l'invasion de la saxe
par frédéric ii de prusse en 1756
déclenché la guerre de sept ans qui voit
les ennemis séculaires france autriche
suède et russie s'opposait la grande
bretagne dans un conflit qui s'étend sur
trois continents c'est en raison de son
caractère global qu'on la considère
parfois comme la première guerre
mondiale
on arrive avec louis 15 dans une période
qui ressemble un peu à la période
contemporaine avec d une europe
extrêmement fragile et des guerres
intra-européennes très nombreuses et
surtout une une mondialisation parce que
nous nous affrontons pour la première
fois très durement avec les anglais et
les espagnols en amérique pour garder
nos possessions d'amérique nous nous
battons en inde aussi beaucoup en 1758
la guerre tourne mal pour la france
frédéric anéantit ses armées lors de la
bataille de rothbach et l'angleterre
menacé colonies aux indes et au canada
en 1757 louis 15 survie à un coup de
couteau mais ne surmonte pas aussi
facilement la dépression et la
résignation qui suivent le roi est
convaincu d'être sur la mauvaise voie et
abandonne les tentatives de réforme
la population est furieuse d'autos qui
ne se résout pas à quitter sa maîtresse
pour changer la tournure des événements
le ministre de la guerre est démis de
ses fonctions et le duc de choiseul
officiers diplomate et homme d'état
devient le nouveau premier ministre
la guerre va avoir de profondes
conséquences en france et en angleterre
quand elle se termine en 1763 la
quasi-totalité de l'empiré colonial
français en inde et en amérique revient
à la grande bretagne le traité de paris
sera un épisode des plus humiliant pour
la monarchie française
la france évidemment ne se sortira pas
brillamment puisque les anglais vont
nous pas nous anéantir et l'asthme et
récupérer toutes les colonies ou presque
que nous avions au nouveau monde et
c'est à la suite aussi de sa queue eh
oui que la langue française qui était la
langue la plus parlée au monde va
devenir va être écrasé par la langue
anglaise puisque les anglais s'installe
un peu partout là où nous avions nos
colonies choiseul et depuis 10 ans à son
poste de premier ministre
son objectif est que la france
redevienne une grande puissance en 1770
leroy qui ne veut pas d'une autre guerre
est irritée d'apprendre que son ministre
projette de défendre l'espagne contre
l'angleterre dans un conflit au sujet
des îles falkland il devient de plus en
plus renfermé et poursuit sa propre
stratégie dans le but de restaurer la
puissance de la france
des documents révèlent qu'il se servait
d'un réseau d'espions pour mener des
négociations secrètes
tout cela en vain durant la décennie qui
suit la guerre de sept ans des
changements significatifs se produisent
à la cour
madame de pompadour meurt en 1764 à
l'âge de 43 ans
elle a dû user de toutes ses ressources
pour se défendre contre les intrigues et
les cabales d'une cour ligués contre
elle l'extraordinaire capacité de
résistance de la marquise lui a permis
de préserver pendant 20 ans sa relation
avec le roi louis 15 à trouver en elle
une interlocutrice indispensable dans la
gestion de l'état
aujourd'hui elle est considérée comme
une des femmes les plus influentes de
l'histoire de france
madame de pompadour va être une des
maîtresses en titre les plus importantes
de l'histoire de france
elle va rester dix neuf années à la cour
de 1745 à 10 764 on a souvent parlé de
l' influence politique de madame de
pompadour pas en bien d'ailleurs
1 c'est vrai que c'est elle qui est
responsable de l'avènement de choiseul à
l'état mais elle n'a pas fait et défait
les ministres comme on l'a si souvent
dit non madame de pompadour est une
femme qui prend des décisions souvent
très juste qui va tirer un petit peu les
ficelles mais pas autant que cela au
niveau politique
un an plus tard le roi père son fils
unique qui meurent de la tuberculose
le dauphin laisse derrière lui trois
fils dont l'aîné louis auguste héritier
du trône épouse marie-antoinette la
fille de l'archiduchesse d'autriche le
16 mai 1770 dans la chapelle royale de
versailles
elle a 14 ans et louis un an de plus la
jeune archiduchesse a été envoyée en
france pour raffermir l'alliance si
fragile avec l'autriche
[Musique]
la maire marie meurt en 1768 l'année
suivante
jane b q comtesse du barry devient la
maîtresse officielle du roi sa relation
conflictuelle avec choiseul permet aux
intrigants de le faire destituer et
remplacer par rené nicolas de maupéou
aux yeux du monde
les pertes territoriale et la débauche
de la cour conduisent la france à sa
perte et dans le pays le mécontentement
s'amplifie
[Musique]
les deux caractéristiques du règne de
louis 15 sont le déclin de l'autorité
royale et la montée de la bourgeoisie le
siècle des lumières est passée par là le
peuple pense par lui même la parole et
sa nouvelle arme bocquier avocat
marchand écrivain acteur artisan et
artiste commence à diffuser plus
largement leur opinion et à une phrase
terrible de l'historien jules michelet
qu'il y ait après voltaire et rousseau
de toute façon la révolution était fait
c'est à dire qu' il y avait eu quelque
chose qui s'étaient débloquées dans les
esprits il y avait eu des livres qui
s'était beaucoup vendu on peut ajouter
aussi montesquieu et cette théorie des
pouvoirs qui plus du tout la théorie
nous éloigne complètement de la
monarchie médiévale son analyse de la
monarchie constitutionnelle britannique
est vraiment à partir de là on était on
est dans quelque chose d'assez près
révolutionnaire dans le domaine
artistique
le rejet du baroque du rococo reflète
les courants politiques populaires qui
critique un gouvernement faible et
corrompue et multiplie les attaques
contre les détenteurs de privilèges
certains peintres formé au style rococo
se tourner vers le réalisme et met en
avant la simplicité et la dignité de
l'homme du peuple pendant que boucher se
souvenait encore au goût de la noblesse
le tableau de jean baptiste greuze
intitulé l'accord des deux villages qui
trouve son inspiration dans la vie
quotidienne du peuple est acclamé par
les philosophes des lumières en raison
de son message moralisateur l'honnêteté
et la bonté des pauvres gens et mis en
valeur pour montrer la décadence morale
des aristocrates greuze s'inspire des
hollandais mais il ne se sent pas obligé
de prêcher chardin à travers la couleur
la lumière et la composition montre la
dignité et la beauté des objets du
quotidien
dans les dernières années du règne de
louis 15 le message est clair et fort
le pays a besoin de réformes politiques
religieuses et économiques radicales
mais la france manque d'hommes d'état
courageux pour montrer le chemin en 1771
les réformes reprennent sous la
direction de maupéou quand les
parlements remettent une fois de plus en
question le pouvoir du roi son premier
ministre
orchestre un coup d'état tous les
magistrats sont arrêtés exilé est
remplacé par des hommes triés sur le
volet on tend à nouveau d'imposer les
classes privilégiées ou exemptés de
taxes mais dès la mort du roi
les anciens magistrats sont rappelés et
maupéou et remplacer le système perdure
un sans connaître aucune réforme
jusqu'à la révolution louez souhaite le
bonheur de ces sujets mais il ne prend
aucune mesure pour assurer leur intérêt
un souverain plus fort reçu sortir de
l'impasse où les classes privilégiées
conduisent le pays et aurait mené à bien
les réformes mais il fallait pour cela
affronter les classes aisées fermement
accrochés à leurs privilèges
louis 15 échoue avant tout parce qu'il
est incapable de réunir les intérêts en
conflit il y a
un bouillonnement des idées auxquelles
le roi ben le roi est un peu étranger
parce que ça n'intéresse pas il n'aime
pas trop les querelles strictement
intellectuelle pendant le règne de louis
15 les parlements s'agitent les
parlements gigote un peu l'un des
ministres louis 15 qui appelle monsieur
de maupeou essaye de les brimer de les
exilés donc le parlement commence à
vouloir se manifester vigoureusement la
révolution française est une révolution
de bourgeois ce n'est pas une révolution
populaire sont les bourgeois qui vont
faire évoluer les idées jeanne
antoinette poisson n'est-elle pas
bourgeoise et c'est tout ce mouvement
bourgeois qui depuis des années prête à
la noblesse qui depuis des années ne
peut pas jouir de pouvoir alors même
qu'elles financent et bien va se
retourner sous louis 15 vers cette
noblesse et tout doucement commencé à
prendre du pouvoir et la philosophie
plus tout le reste va faire que la
révolution française va commencer à
fourmiller va les idées l'évolution des
idées va commencer à fouiller en france
l'un des 10 715 avait vu renaître
l'espoir
en 1774 celui ci a disparu ou quasiment
l'angleterre l'autriche et la russie
sont de plus en plus puissantes
la france a perdu sa suprématie le
mécontentement accumulé au cours des
deux guerres et des dernières années du
règne de louis 15 s'est transformé en
indignation général louis le bien aimé
n'enverra pas l'explosion finale
il meurt en 1774 de la variole et est
enterré en la basilique de saint-denis
où reposent les rois de france
c'est son petit fils qui lui succède
prenant le nom de louis saez
louis 15 a régné pendant près de
soixante ans il a reçu le surnom
affectueux de biens aimés au début de
son règne
quand il était beau jeune et que le pays
vivait en paix et dans la prospérité
il est vrai que le peuple était alors
plus heureux qui ne l'avait été son
prédécesseur louis xiv et que la
discrétion du nouveau monarque a
peut-être masquer l'importance de ces
réalisations
mais durant la seconde moitié de son
règne
l'échec du gouvernement dans les
domaines de la politique de l'économie
et de la morale va mener la monarchie
vers son déclin
au cours des années qui suivent la mort
de louis 15 les voies sera sans la
france devient de plus en plus
consciente d'elle-même
le peuple veut partager les
responsabilités avec le gouvernement il
désire voir régner la tolérance
religieuse et se mettre en place une
nouvelle vision de l'agriculture source
principale de la richesse nationale
selon les critères de son époque louis
15 n'était pas un mauvais homme sa
tragédie qui fut celle de la france
c'est qu'il avait hérité d'une fonction
qu'il n'aimait pas et d'un système
politique qui exigeait plus d'esprit
d'initiative qu'il n'en était capable
il a été au pouvoir pendant une période
de changement radical des idées
politiques sociales et intellectuelles
le monde se transformait dans tous les
domaines intellectuels commercial
artistiques politiques et
constitutionnelles en l'absence de toute
réforme
la monarchie est apparu de plus en plus
figée et arrogante
à la fin du règne de louis 15 son
caractère mystique a quasiment disparu
toutes les institutions ont perdu leur
prestige la noblesse et ses privilèges
l'église et son intolérance les
parlements et leur mauvaise volonté
l'armée et sa corruption une monarchie
plus engagé
souple et forte à la fois aurait sans
doute su pérenniser l'autocratie dans le
coeur et dans l'esprit de ses citoyens
d'un autre côté les forces en jeu était
peut-être trop puissante pour qu'un seul
homme puisse y résister pour louis 15
intelligent mais en conflit avec lui
même qui possédait un jugement fin mais
manqué trop de confiance pour agir
la situation était trop complexe pour
qu'il puisse la gérer convenablement
malgré une jeunesse douloureuse et un
lourd héritage louis 15 rassembla ses
forces pour sauvegarder le régime de
monarchie absolue qu'il transmit à son
petit fils louis 16 mai sa célèbre
phrase après moi le déluge montre qu'il
était parfaitement conscient du fait que
son pays allait vers une révolution
qu'il ne savait comment empêcher